In the previous lesson we discussed black box
testing, which is the testing performed based on a
description of the software, but without considering any of
software's internal details. In this lesson, we will discuss
the counterpart of black box testing, which is called
unsurprisingly white box testing or structural testing. And just
like we did for black box testing, we will
cover the main characteristics of white box testing and
this casts the most commonly used white box testing techniques. We
will conclude the lesson with the discussion of the main strengths and
limitations of white box testing. So that you will know, when to
use it? How to use it? And what to expect from it?